[Música]
Bueno pero antes de que llegue este
sábado y toda la coronación vamos a
hablar primero de economía para ello
tenemos a nuestra compañera Daniela
hablando bienvenida Muchas gracias
Rodrigo bueno Dani vamos a empezar
hablando de salarios de lo que también
se hablaba en este último reporte pero
esta vez en Estados Unidos que busca
alzar sus salario mínimo así es Pues el
senador de Bernie Sanders quien compitió
con Joe biden en las primarias
demócratas y hoy es el presidente del
comité de Salud Educación trabajo y
pensiones planea presentar un proyecto
de ley para subir este ingreso
argumentando que las ganancias
corporativas están disparando pues
Espera que este senador independiente lo
lleve el 14 de junio a esta al senado
para después llevarlo a todo el pleno
veamos En qué consiste la iniciativa
nadie en este país puede sobrevivir con
7,25 dólares la hora y tal vez algunos
de mis colegas En el congreso quieran
vivir
con 7 dólares y 25 centavos la hora y
ver qué se siente no puedes hacerlo con
9 dólares la hora no puedes hacerlo con
12 dólares la hora necesitamos una
economía en la que todos nuestros
trabajadores ganen un salario digno no
es aceptable hoy que casi 35 millones de
trabajadores estadounidenses ganen menos
de 17 dólares por hora
Bueno pero de salarios ya veníamos
hablando en Estados Unidos esta semana
por la huelga de los guionistas de
Hollywood Ahora son los estudios de esa
industria los que salen en defensa claro
iba a decir que no se está ganando un
salario mínimo como el que estaba
hablando Bernie Sanders después de la
alianza de productores de cine y
televisión que representa a los
principales estudios Como por ejemplo
Disney o Netflix de Hollywood respondió
a las afirmaciones de los trabajadores
de cine y televisión en paro desde el
martes que se quejan los cambios
provocados por la era del streaming que
les reduce su semana de trabajo o la
demanda que han tenido de trabajo entre
otros dicen que la mayoría tiene
garantizado determinado número de
semanas de trabajo y que tienen
beneficios que otros no como por ejemplo
la atención médica también
contribuciones al plan de pensiones y
licencia por paternidad paga también
agregó este gremio que un libretista de
una serie trabaja fijo entre 20 y 24
semanas por cada serie con un pago
mínimo de 91 mil dólares más lo que
ellos llaman ingresos futuros o
residuales de más de 28.000 dólares por
cada guión de media hora y 41 mil
dólares para un guión de una de una hora
por ahora hay programas que están
teniendo que salir repetidos este paro
ya afectado por ejemplo a detonate show
de Jimmy fallan también date Knight with
set mayores y the Lake show entre muchos
otros
y parece que todavía Seguiremos unos
días con esta disputa Daniela vamos a
seguir en este país que todavía nos da
más noticias y es que ha sido una semana
crítica para la banca Regional de
Estados Unidos Claro porque recordemos
que se dio el tercer colapso bancario en
menos de dos meses el de First Bank a
comienzos de esta semana Ahora el
mercado se pregunta Quiénes podrían ser
las próximas víctimas y comienzan a
sonar nombres por un lado está Paco
Esteban corp Este es el banco número 53
por nivel de activos en Estados Unidos
con sede en Los Ángeles tiene 67
sucursales casi todas en California
esta compañía acaba de anunciar que
explora opciones estratégicas incluida
una posible venta sus acciones han
perdido más del 70% de su valor este año
y están en mínimos históricos poco más
de 3 dólares en la lista también está
Western Alliance cuya acción también se
derrumbó a pesar de que ha tratado de
calmar a los inversionistas sobre su
salud financiera
delgado que vaya a vender su operación
En todo caso son varios bancos sobre
todo los regionales los que están
atravesando por esa situación Porque
además hay un nerviosismo entre los
depositantes que están comenzando a
retirar su dinero Obvio claro escuchan
que puede haber problemas con los bancos
y obviamente entra el miedo pero en
principio No deberíamos preocuparnos en
principio
no hay que seguir haciendo el análisis
con estos bancos sobre todo los pequeños
Bueno pues Seguiremos Daniela ahora por
el momento nos vamos a México en donde
descendió el desempleo Pues en el tercer
mes del año correspondió al dos coma
cuatro por ciento de la población
económicamente activa esto según el
Instituto Nacional de estadística un
dato menor al 2,7% de febrero y al 3% de
un año antes sin embargo esta
estadística mexicana siempre se ve
empañada por su tasa de informalidad que
hoy es del 55% afecta más de 33 millones
de ciudadanos también por la brecha
laboral de género pues menos de la mitad
de las mujeres en edad de trabajar
tienen un empleo mientras que en el caso
de los hombres la proporción es de casi
un 80 por ciento Daniel cifra del día
94.800 millones de dólares estas fueron
las ventas del gigante Apple en el
primer trimestre con un descenso del dos
coma cinco por ciento integral datos
claves sus ventas de iPhone subieron a
pesar de que los consumidores vienen
limitando sus gastos a lo estrictamente
necesario en medio de esta y me
vertiginosa inflación Pero lo que sí
está cayendo bruscamente son las ventas
del Mac y de los ipads Pues también
interesante es datos yo no tengo un
iPhone Daniela Así que no sé si algún
día llegaré a comprarlo Muchas gracias
por este repaso económico te invito a
que sigas con nosotros en directo allá